那我今天就從開發的角度啊
給大家體驗一下到底AI給我們帶來甚麼樣的一個開發的改變
為甚麼這麼多程序人從高薪變成了事業啊
對那我們來體驗一下
好
那我呃
其實我在10年前就開始創業了
然後啊
這邊好幾個老闆啊
甚麼林成光啊
那些都是我第一次創業的時候認識的
那時候我們做的就是一個叫台灣游學啊
就那時候
福建的開放了自由行啊
就以前大陸人是不能去台灣的
啊
突然在2012年左右開放了自由行
那那時候呢
我就覺得
誒
我很想創業
對吧
因為我就是
很喜歡想這種佔面性的問題
哪些生意能做
哪些可以把它做成
對吧
那我就覺得
台灣如果開放我們可以去那邊做甚麼生意呢
然後我就覺得台灣能厲害的是甚麼
你們知道是甚麼嗎
是那些創業廣告
甚麼看到人哭啊
看到人笑啊
我覺得
誒那時候那邊的廣告公司非常厲害
4A廣告公司
然後我們就組了一個公司
專門帶全中國的傳媒大學的人過去
4A廣告公司學習
拿證書
然後方便他們未來能夠更快的就業啊
然後簡歷上能夠增加一筆好看的
那個那個面試的提升他們的競爭力
然後呢
第一次創業了
做了這個事情
做這個事情要做甚麼呢
對吧
必須你跟別人談合作
你得有個網站
對吧
然後呢
做完網站
跟別人談完合作
很多客戶來報名
那你得有個CIA系統吧
對吧
那時候我是不會寫程序的
所以我就找外面的人開發
然後他找他們開發的最少給三五萬
然後呢
每個月我已經有設計師
有客服
有各種員工在公司裡面
一個月花五萬塊錢吧
然後等他開發
我要不要對需求
又要每個月再給他三五萬塊錢
這公司還沒開始運行
我已經花了二三十萬了
對吧
一毛錢還沒這麼
你說招得到生嗎
也不知道啊
對吧
你只是有這個idea而已
已經花了十幾二十萬了
所以現在呢
不一樣了
有AI出來了
改變非常大
你有甚麼想法
你可以快速的做個工作台
做個系統
做個閉環
來驗證一下
到底他是不是真的有需求
然後第二次創業呢
為甚麼第一家公司倒閉了
因為台灣自由行結束了啊
就
就一二年到一五年啊
選舉一改
沒有自由行啊
所以第一家公司就倒閉了
然後呢
我就在想
哎
我很喜歡做投資啊
這方面的工作啊
然後就覺得
哇
如果投資每天都要盯盤
看
靠意自利
甚麼自律
啊甚麼最重要的是自律啊
資金管理
我說這些是計算機最擅長的事情嗎
對吧
那我就去學代碼
就是為了偷懶而已
我就說
哎
代碼本來就能做了
有人自動化
為甚麼還要靠意自利去學習去做呢
然後來呢
發現
哎
開了一個量化公司
跟別合伙了
最值錢的東西呢
就是我們花了大量的
無論是找投資人進來投資
到底投資甚麼呢
就請高端的程序員過來
開發這個量化交易系統
怎麼樣從數據到
有時候
比如說剛剛的朋友問的
怎麼讓它7乘以24小時運行啊
你怎麼不屬於服務
怎麼拿數據
怎麼通過你的算法做決策
最後令到它
令這個系統是安全穩定
可迭代的
發展的一個系統
最後最少投了1000萬
才做好了這樣的一個系統而已
所以我們說
AI真正出來啊
就是讓每個人都能有一個
滿足你個性化需求的系統
那具體怎麼來做呢
今天是我分享的內容了
所以我們說
真的是
那個查理盲格說的啊
真正的成功呢
是你要做出一個系統
它可以讓你的失敗
不斷的修正
讓你的失敗越來越難的一個系統
而不是天天說
我要靠自律
我要靠改變自己甚麼的
不要太相信自己的意志力啊
OK
就是要做一個系統
來協助你更高效
更快速的
然後正反饋的一個工作
對吧
就像紅總的工作台
我省去了很多工作
每天打開就看到熱點
打開就知道我
今天可以寫甚麼了
打開就能看到數據反饋
最後我就能做決策了
因為最後真正的財富
不是創造一個有價值的產品
而是要創造一個人
持續生產有價值的東西的系統啊
OK
好
所以你能看到我們自己啊
身邊越優秀的同學啊
越被裁員了
現在好幾個朋友最近
就在一兩個月的事情
電話非常快了
越是乾到忠誠的
寫代碼的
管理層的
因為為甚麼被裁員啊
AI太厲害了
這是一個點
第二點是他們實在太貴了
對吧
好幾個朋友啊
被外派到新加坡了
或者是在頂端的
私募通知工作了
這兩三個月來找我聊天的
都是被裁員的
甚至是下個月有了找我聊創業的
都是在抖音商裡面被裁員的朋友啊
找龍哥吃吃飯
看看有甚麼創業idea
畢竟拿到了畢業獎金對吧
那為甚麼會越來越來越多人被裁員呢
你可以看到一個很大的變化啊
就是程序員以前呢
是很累很多工作量的
我先我開拍一個東西
我先要看API的文檔
不懂了文檔
我要寫代碼
我要測試
然後我還要找到問題
然後修改成我需要的需求的系統
然後最後呢
慢慢修bug寫文檔各種
現在呢
現在的我們的工作啊
只有三件事情
你跟AI講清楚需求
對吧
這第一個
第二個是甚麼呢
你選好控制器
讓它能夠工作
第三個甚麼呢
你做好驗收的標準
我們只需要做三件事
很多人說
哇學AI到底學甚麼呀
你不是在學AI
你要搞清楚
AI是人家Deepseek的那些團隊
來研究的AI
你只是在補足AI的不足
完成你的需求
對吧
到底AI不能做甚麼
才是你們要學了
AI不能做甚麼
它缺了甚麼東西
我們要補足它來完成我的目標
這個才是你們要
你們不要以為自己在學AI
你只是在
用AI
OK
好
所以呢
這半年對我改變非常大了
畢爾蓋遲了發出了一個感嘆
是甚麼東西
求求AI不要發展那麼快了
真的快到離譜
直接就是指數級的增長
三個月前
我還在用小龍蝦的時候
我已經被驚呆了
對吧
從只能回答到
我回去睡覺了
他都在幫我改bug跟寫系統
然後回答了第二天早上一看
沒問題能用我
而且測試我
搞定了
我的需求被滿足了
對吧
結果還不到一兩個月
直接小龍蝦那個開發者
被GPT OpenAI給挖過去了
然後呢
OpenAI就出入了Codex了
沒兩下騰訊最厲害的是甚麼
你有我也要有
你不管我怎麼有的
反正我也有
然後就八點就出來了
OK
所以這幾個月
其實對我的工作方式
跟工作的模式
跟我不斷思考的東西
有極大的變化
你們可以看到這個PVT這麼漂亮
對吧
其實我都沒有打開過
PVT這個軟件
就做出來了
OK
好
那第一個改變是甚麼呢
就我已有的工作
它可以是一個放大器
AI到底是甚麼東西
它第一個是我們的放大器
我過去做了十年的量化研究
對吧
那中間會有甚麼
會有一些細節
可能我做得不夠好的
不夠完整的
然後還有很多新的橫向的
比如說美股市場啊
別的市場我可能沒做過
對吧
那它橫向的也可以快速的
寫大量的代碼來幫我做測試
找通用性啊
解決過度擬合的問題啊
等等等等
它能夠加快你的效率
最少十倍以上
這是第一個
不要再來問老師說
AI你能不能變現啊
這些問題是很低級的
知道嗎
因為第一個事情
它已經把你的效率提升了十倍
特別是你已經乾過十年的工作
OK
第二個呢
是你A到B點的效率
時間直接縮短
你們可以看到啊
為甚麼美股市場
現在漲的股票都是哪些啊
對吧
一開始是英偉達啊
超微啊
為甚麼會漲啊
因為它提供了算力
算力解決了模型
模型幫助大部分的人
提升了他們的效率
A到B點
本來要十天
現在變成了一天
對吧
只要是能夠在裡面工作的
它就能夠
有
大家就願意付錢
是不是這個問題
你願意付那個token費嗎
你是願意的
因為你從A到B點
時間直接縮短了很多倍
你感受到了
你一段
現在很多朋友啊
充了co-dex了
第二個月
突然沒token了
很焦慮
你吸毒很辛苦
就被螞蟻咬一樣
因為我A到B突然變得很遠了
對吧
所以A到B點
這個還是生意
像培訓也是一種生意
為甚麼
我幫你從A到B點
先從零開始了
你起碼知道有這個東西了
去走這個A到B了
那B點最終啊
現在為甚麼存儲
長得這麼牛逼
昨天那個林老闆
我打開他的電腦
他叫我幫他裝co-dex
結果他的C盤和D盤
是滿的
對吧
因為為甚麼呢
你要把
後面我會講
我會詳細講這個東西
就是現在AI不斷的生成文件
甚麼腳本
很多人寫代碼
生出來
我都不知道沒看過
都看不懂
對吧
但是你的盤
馬上就變成了
不夠用了
所以這個就是為甚麼存儲這麼厲害
好
那第三個點呢
如果A到B點
縮短了那麼多
那未來的
很多人被裁員
甚麼意思呢
像我朋友
這是來當助教
他在微重銀行工作的
對吧
他說
我身邊被裁了四五個同事
結果老闆
叫我一個人用coco
一個人乾四個人的活
對吧
我可能是
比以前還累
我以為我有AI
我是可以找下班的那一個
結果發現隔壁同事不見了
我在乾四個人的活
OK
但是呢
我要跟大家講
就是現在的一個設計師
假設
你是有了AI
你是可以直接是
做PTT
做視頻
做網站
甚麼都可以做
做你的工作台
對吧
所以你可以變成了
乘以N的A到B
這個就是AI時代需要的能力
你能不能跨界的
擁有別人平時工作的那種能力啊
就像我我壓根也不會寫網站也不會寫後台
這次課程的所有的東西都是我用AI搞定的
所以說台上三小時啊
台下我加班了三十個小時
但是呢
Poken呢
我超了差不多300個小時
OK
所以你要感受到這個AI的不一樣
一個人
以後老闆交代任務給你
你不要說
我沒時間
我不會做
對吧
不會有這樣的問題了
因為
那問題是甚麼
就是你用AI不夠厲害
所以我們說了
AI我經常在想啊
到底它對商業模式有甚麼變化呢
大家可能現在沒甚麼體感
但是很快了
馬上一到兩年後
就會有很大的變化
可能你們慢慢的會感覺到
第一個
我要在孫宇晨裡面要說
最近很火的一個人
他講過一句話
我很佩服這個人的判斷力啊
但他人品無感說是不太行的
只是說
他很早就說了
能跟AI聊的工作
不要跟人聊
對吧
我就是一個這麼懶的人
你跟我說
我要跟別人聊工作
聊細節
我會很生氣
所以有時候
我跟別人聊工作
我就是脾氣不太好了
因為第一
你都沒聽懂我要甚麼
對吧
第二你回答的到底是甚麼呀
我的天啊
對吧
第三你做出來的又是甚麼
所以呢
未來呢
能跟AI聊的執行
不要跟人聊
那跟人聊了
大部分就是怎麼樣去
資源
OK
好
突然
冷靜了下來
好
就是
能跟別人多聊的
就是資源的整合
怎麼樣市場的配合
對吧
你有甚麼資源
我有甚麼資源
怎麼能讓那個
並行的項目更多
對吧
我們能創造更多的價值
而不是說這個執行的細節
要怎麼做好啊
你不要以為你想的東西跟你做的東西
能比AI好
一開始我也是這麼想的
後來我發現
PPT他做的比我好一百倍
網站比我厲害太多了
所以你們要先放下自己的那種
但是你如果有實內經驗的
說不定你都不用下載
你才是最厲害的那個東西呀
好
所以第二個呢
我們說的數字資產到底是甚麼
其實AI現在甚麼都能做了
但是問題就是
你要有自己的
屬於自己的體系的
包括公司需要
那為甚麼需要這些啊
因為你要發連愛更懂你
你要發一個任務給他
他能夠交出你真的想要的東西
那他缺了甚麼
缺了就是知識庫
數據庫
代碼庫
甚至我說做視頻的
你有沒有你的風格的素材庫
做過成功的一些廣告的庫
能夠沈澱下來讓系統
反復調用
反復迭代
反復升級
有沒有這樣的東西
然後最後你的系統就是可以通過
AI能夠越來越懂你了以後啊
你可以創造一個不斷可以升級自學習的
為甚麼人家
Cloud Code跟
跟OpenAI都說
好像我現在的程序開發都沒有用冷血了
都是AI自動
那個增長速度是非常可怕的
人家OpenAI都說可能
不知道明年年底和近年年底
就要實現AGI了
AGI說連AI有自我意識了
有可能是這樣子的啊
但目前還在討論在那邊
就只要撇除了人這個關卡
所以我們經常說系統升級到底升級甚麼
你就要看到整個系統裡面最浪費時間
對吧
最沒有效率和效益的那一塊要被它被優化掉
然後你就會發現
人就是那一塊最沒有效益的
沒有效益的環節
如果你那AI的代碼你還要去審查
還要去各種測試
那你其實也沒提高效率多少
這個是吳文達說的
那
所以呢
我們可以看到啊
這個都不是甚麼幾年前
幾個月前
這些東西呢
就跟考古一樣的啊
哦
沒錯了
Town很重要
但是現在呢
更重要的是甚麼
就是
這就是一個月一個月的事情啊
過去我要學Punk
再來我要學AI工具
再來我要設計我的員工
Agent 怎麼去運作
怎麼閉環一個工作人員
那現在呢
我們要想的是
怎麼帶一個真正的數字員工
他可以長期穩定的完成一些論諾啊
所以關鍵的是甚麼呢
就跟那邊科達的老師姐講的很清楚
很相似的
關鍵就是
撇除這些啊
先要有你自己的一個庫
無論是文章的知識庫
還是數據庫
還是代碼庫
還是素材庫
這些你要有
再來呢就是
用上最好的模型
再用上控制器
Harness
就是我今天會講的重點之重的一個內容
到底甚麼是Harness
怎麼構建Harness
怎麼能Harness來替你工作
最後你就會有一個真正的數字員工
等你數字員工一多了
你就是搭建了一個
所謂的系統啊
好
那為甚麼要來今天下課啊
好 其實呢有幾個點燃
第一個是很多朋友啊
他們可能平時上班也很忙
沒有時間跟沈浸式用AI啊
這第一個
第二個呢是能夠獲得一些啓發
對吧
看到老師哦
他可以開發這個
開發那個對他工作都有幫助
能夠得到一些啓發
然後再來我們能夠真正的手把手
無論是幫你們解決安裝問題
還是一些不同的技術問題
讓你們快速高效的能夠
打通這個直接摸到對吧
摸到最強模型的一個門檻
這次呢我除了這些視頻
是找我同事做的啊
陳子健啊
他專門做視頻的
我說
那你能不能幫我做幾個視頻
給我看一看啊
OK
那這個也就是一句提示時就生出來了
也就五秒鐘
但是這不要全的啊
OK
那這個是甚麼意思呢
就是說現在啊
你可以看到
無論刷抖音還是看小公書
你看到現在的那些創業者啊
年紀越來越小了
可能16歲就一定說我做了幾個APP了
13歲的都有
所以我們說現在不再次問你工作
有多少年經驗啊
或怎麼樣的
執行有多厲害啊
沒有這回事了
問的就是你的AI年紀
到底你用過深度用過AI多久
開發過甚麼產品
有沒有用度反饋
對吧
是不是真的能跑起來一個穩定的系統
這個才是最關鍵的事情啊
所以我們叫AI-Edge啊
所以老提示來學習的時候呢
可能要先判斷一下自己的AI年紀到哪裡了
像昨天好幾個朋友啊
就覺得我都已經會用Codex了
我還要學更好的東西
那到底是學甚麼呢
你的AI年紀到哪裡了
有的可能
哇我昨天才剛裝WiBody
對吧
那你就要知道
我下一步到底要去
怎麼更深的去實操啊
好
那這個就看P-P-P就可以了
開始使用
我要多用啊
一定要多用
那再來呢
就是怎麼要把你的工作變得更強
OK
能夠那一個任務除了重復
能夠Loop起來啊
給它一個指令
它就跑通了
那下一步呢
它如果你想加一些新功能
你怎麼加到這個工作流裡面
讓它再一次升級
然後又跑通
這是第二等級的
第三等級呢
就甚至是它能夠
提升你的工作
幫你做一些
厲害的決策
好
還有另外一個要學習的就是
我們從技術的角度來
給大家教這幾個東西
怎麼讓模型它的反應更快
更省錢
然後呢
我們用HONNESS
讓它做得更准
這個是我重點會講的內容啊
大家可以
好說今天的課啊
到講了那麼多
五官重要的話
今天才把布魯秀出來了
待會我想的課
主要有五張啊
第一張是
怎麼樣用上最強的模型
先拿到結果
你才能真正理解AI的邊界
不要你用了一個很弱的模型
然後你會
哎呀
生存出來的東西還不如我自己做的
對吧
那你就不懂它真正搶到哪裡去了
是怎麼理解你的任務
來選擇我們說的架構
這個很重要啊
然後第三個呢
是我們怎麼樣
讓AI能夠
調工具
因為現在的工具呢
不再是開發給人用的
是開發給你的Agen用的
並且它可以通過你的自然語言
就可以去用了
那怎麼讓它自動用
第四個呢
是怎麼讓它能夠通過你的控制
能夠穩定的交付你想要的東西
甚至是自動化的去交付
第五個呢
怎麼更厲害的去創造一個多Agen的一個項目啊
好
開始講脫口秀了
OK
第一個呢
是我們說的
其實它有點像神仙的對吧
為甚麼像神仙
我們來看一下
這也是直接幫忙做的
就是說現在有很多的模型都很厲害
能夠幫你解決很多問題
但是你會發現它們都有這幾個特徵啊
第一個是
有求必應對吧
你只要能付錢
你問它
它就能給你
跟神仙一樣對吧
你這個巴仙的位置看啊
你只要去廟里求它
它就會給你有求必應啊
第二個它擁有很高超的智商
OK
第三個是
可能要給點香油錢對吧
你要去求它
你要給香油錢
第四個呢
它是真的住在雲上面的
在天障的
因為我們說雲服務器嘛
你要調用它
你要調用雲的功能啊
OK
所以我們說的大模型呢
它就是會產出
能力強
然後呢
是一個
要乾活就沒有免費加班
一定要給錢的一個
一個員工啊
然後第四個呢
它是在雲端的
好
我從技術的角度
再簡單講一下
這個大模型啊
為甚麼說Transform了
它有這麼強的人力
你第一代呢
我們說你是給它文字
對吧
然後呢
它
只能跟你聊天吧
然後怎麼樣升級到現在
還能執行呢
簡單講一下
第一個
它用了一種做法
因為計算機呢
是沒辦法直接知道
自然語言的
它需要呢
比如說老闆這個詞
它會變成了詞項量
所以你們呢
如果聽到甚麼
呃
embedding這種事情
這種內容啊
它就變成一個多維的一個
坐標
ok
然後變成了坐標以後呢
它本身訓練好的模型呢
是很多維度的一些
一些
內容啊
它會串聯
概率上
你說這個詞
是跟甚麼有意思
然後會找到那個維度
相近的東西
理解你的意圖
最後呢
輸出一個最高概率的一些文字啊
那通過現在有Codex啊
小龍蝦這種東西
它可以用把你的詞
輸出的意圖跟文字
轉化成直行的步驟
所以呢
你每一次調用
你其實就是把你的自然語言
給到大模型
它去搜索
最後呢
給你一段文字
通過Agent
變成執行任務和步驟
最後把你執行出來了
那多模態呢
你無論是輸入聲音
圖片
它都能變成詞相用
最後呢
能夠找到你的意圖
所以怎麼省token
這裡就很明確了
你只要給的東西夠明確
它就不用到處找了
它也不用
不理解你甚麼意思
或者做錯對吧
所以呢
無論是POM
還是Context
這種上下文和
和意圖
你要表達得很清楚
那你就不會亂燒
不可能
所以馬斯克呢
講過一個例子是甚麼呢
就說啊
現在
人跟大模型的區別啊
就跟大模型跟大星星一樣的邏輯
對
因為你不可能有計算機這麼多維度的一個知識
儲備量
所以我們呢
一定要
對吧
多跟他求求
求求求給我點甚麼工作
多去求你就不會用AI了
好
所以你們也要理解一下你們電腦的一些調用的過程啊
就如果你是發資料啊
發各種文字給他
那有些模型
它是
對某些模型
它是比較差的
所以我們一般用的就是
那個GPT
5.6
那你輸入了
無論是資料
代碼
圖片
它都能夠變成Transformer的向量
給你返回一些
你要的一個一個執行目標
那每一步的都是收錢的
OK
所以這裡就來了
那我先問一個問題啊
我先不打開這個頁面
讓大家思考一下
那你覺得
如果我們在AI面前是大星星的話
那他有甚麼不能做的呀
那他不是啥都做了就好了呀
他有甚麼邊界
他有甚麼部署
有沒有人可以
思考一下
嗯
他真的無敵了嗎
情感上
情感上是一個
還有嗎
沒有慾望
要賺你錢了
都沒有慾望
他有甚麼不足呢
我們到底要做甚麼呢
他沒有創造性
也是
所以我們要搞清楚啊
他有試到很強的邊界啊
第一個他有可能會是錯的
因為他畢竟是一個干預輸出嘛
你如果用的更差的模型
他出的干預就更高了
OK
所以我們第一個我們要有一些人工審核的環節
保證他不會出錯
出很離谷的錯
第二個呢
它是沒有你企業的私有化數據的啊
OK
我們這個要檢索啊
更差的模型,它錯的概率就更高了
所以我們第一個要有一些人工審核的環節
保證它不會出錯,出很離譜的錯
第二個呢,它是沒有你企業的私有化數據的
我們這個叫檢索,Reachible
就是怎麼樣檢索到你公司本來有的私有數據
還有一些memory,你公司是做啥的
有甚麼成本啊,費用啊,他也不可能知道啊
對吧,所以你要提供這些讓AI更懂你
所以為甚麼經常人家在抖音上面都說
啊,我怎麼教你搭知識庫啊,wag
wag那個增強檢索啊等等的一些東西
為甚麼讓你做這些
因為AI確實沒辦法完全能理解你的意圖啊
那第三個是它也沒有實時的數據
比如說像像紅總說我調那些小紅樹的API來拿那個實時數據
為甚麼我要做這個事情啊
因為你問AI它就是沒有啊,對吧
所以我要去不斷的search
不斷的寫API去讀取這些數據
甚至現在我們說有HCP了
就是能夠讓模型呢
統一的去自動化調用了一些工具了
那第三個它也不,第四個啊
它也不受控制,說實在了
如果你不寫Hunners
跟不告訴它要用甚麼工具的話
它可能就亂來了
可能生成出來的東西不是你想要也沒有按照你的風格的要求啊
所以這個呢就是我們試到要真正去學習的東西啊
好,再來我們還要看懂模型啊
就是說有時候你用的時候說啊怎麼這麼慢啊怎麼那麼貴啊怎麼那麼笨對吧
那我們去哪裡看這個信息呢
有一個網站啊,我這裡沒有,就artificial.ai啊
artificial.ai
這個網站就是實時的公佈 比如說這個月又出新模型 下個月又出一個新模型 那它這個象限怎麼看呢?
這裡呢 這個位置就是最厲害 最強的 也是最貴的 因為下面這個是價格 重軸是它的自商 那為什麼你看啊 GPT 的它是性價比 這個領域就屬於性價比最高的綠色 它又聰明 又不貴 是吧 那這個呢
我們那個騰訊裡面做遊戲的朋友
他說我一個月可能差8000美金左右
他就是用CALCODE的
因為時代貴
但是反攻率低啊
對吧
我只要